alors les faillites d'entreprises
pourraient détruire jusqu'à 200 milles
leur emploi selon les projections le lot
fce et vous avez vous peur de perdre
votre emploi mais on vous a posé la
question regarder oui c'est pour ça que
j'ai démissionné changé d'un poil en
revanche je travaille dans le secteur de
l'alimentaire et maintenant je suis allé
vers le métier de militaire
famille car mes terres pourquoi attaquer
qu'est-ce qui vous inquiétez pas ce que
la crise il ya beaucoup de magasins ont
dû fermer surtout les petits
indépendants alors que l'on va perdre et
on des fonctionnaires les plus sûres
bah oui parce que du coup en fait ce qui
se passe c'est que moi je vais finir mes
études et en fait c'est vraiment
compliqué pour trouver un emploi même
pour postuler donc la jeune maman si je
vais pas changer de secteur et
recommencent à des études en fait pas
vraiment chance mois en alternance et je
sais que c'est une super formation et
pour la suite il y aura pas forcément de
soucis enfin je me dis qu'il ya quand
même des marchés sur lesquels savons que
ça donc il y aura toujours de l'emploi
qui hésite parce que
de plus de la crise d'un gp de
transition jeu
je recherche un nouvel emploi j'ai est
normal de retrouver et là je suis apte
contractuels
qui est renouvelé chaque mois
sapin
en fin de contrat j'ai la boule au
ventre fois s'est passé votre nouveau
pas donc il va il avoue rien sur le
marché un emplacement n'a quasiment pas
d'offre
on a beau postuler on avoue chercher ce
sont soit des cdd après claire qu'on
propose
après toujours rien de sécurisant fait
franchement ça rien de sécurisant
un petit peu c'est vu que je suis chef
de cuisine je ne travaille pas depuis
maintenant trois mois
depuis le 2ème confinement est forcément
oui je suis inquiet parce que c'est pas
ce que ça va donner
ou alors on nous dit qu'on va reprendre
vers le
le 20 janvier après on entend
on entend début février on entend même
maintenant début mars on est forcément
je suis inquiet je dois dire que oui et
non parce que de nos jours surtout en ce
moment par exemple moi j'ai plus de
travail et donc je suis à la recherche
d'un poste je cherchais à travers de
multiples sites
donc du coup j'ai beau envoyer des cv
mais j'ai pas beaucoup de retours donc
avec
avec la crise la ça complique tout
avant il y avait du travail et j'étais
bien de ça j'avais un travail fixe
en fait il ya eu le premier confinement
il m'en a tellement arrêté contrats' a
une influence par celle du poumon pas pu
renouveler et du cou
buzz moi je suis de marseille jeune
elissa après exprime je suis du travail
aux puits bien sûr moi je cherche un
boulot j'en ai trouvé mais avec des
documents confinement mais je peux pas
encore commencé donc c'est compliqué
déjà avant envoyer des cv les
recrutements ça prend du temps alors là
avec le coded
ça a vraiment empirer les choses et il y
aura de moins en moins de boulot